a new Democratic fresh face comes out as
a blatant anti-semite aoc lies about her
own green New Deal and Virginia settles
into place I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show as I've been saying for
the past several weeks one of the
beautiful things about being a Democrat
is the worse you do the more the
headlines read Republicans pounds and
boy there's been a lot of pouncing
lately because it turns out that the
Democratic fresh faces so fresh so face
they all weirdly seem to be coming out
mistakenly as communist and anti-semites
like who would have thought such a thing
except for everyone with half a brain
who's been following this stuff but
we'll get to that in just a second first
let's talk about that watch on your
wrist it's garbage isn't it I mean let's
be real about this whatever you're
wearing on you're a citizen is nice as
this I mean check this thing out this is
really nice watch why because it's from
movement movement makes minimalist
watches that tell you the time and look
really classy doing it it really is
quite simple movement watches sunglasses
other accessories they've been perfect
gifts for families across the country
everyone in my family has a movement
watch pretty much everyone in law's
siblings parents I'm gonna get one for
my children as soon as they're old
enough because movement watches are just
fantastic and you know that I'm about
supporting ground upon Trump Norris who
work hard for what they want which is
why I love movement so much their true
success story makes wearing their
products much more meaningful they came
up and made a name for themselves and
one of the most established markets in
the world they've reached exponential
growth movement watches are all about
looking good while keeping it simple in
they started just 95 bucks you're
looking at up to four hundred bucks for
the same quality from a traditional
brand clean design minimal really
quality products movement has sold
almost 2 million watches in over 160
countries there's a reason why right now
get 15% off today with free shipping and
free returns by going to MVM t.com slash
shapiro now what's great about this is
it's great for Valentine's Day
MVM t.com slash appear they've got new
styles on their site all the time check
out their latest in MDM t.com again MVM
t comm slash up hero join the movement
get 15% off when you go to em VMT comm
slash up hero alright so there's this
new cadre of democrats the fresh faces
so fresh so face and usually we talk in
this context about alexandra Ocasio
cortez don't worry we'll get to her in
just a second but she is not the fresh
face who is making waves over the
weekend instead the fresh face
making waves over the weekend was
blatant anti-semite Ilhan Omar from
Minnesota who has indeed been an
anti-semite for years upon years upon
years and it's not like a big secret
you know it's hilarious is that the same
media that will suggest the entire
Republican Party is anti-semitic because
Donald Trump was once close with some
people who themselves were close with
the all right the same media that will
suggest that the entire Republican Party
by a wide swath is anti-semitic
because of Steve king who by the way is
actually pro-israel that same media will
suggest that the Democratic Party has no
problem with anti-semitism at all
they're just asking the hard questions
this is something that Dave Weigel of
the Washington Post tweeted out about
Ilhan Omar so let's start from the
beginning
Johan Omar's record okay so Ilhan Omar
back in 2012 tweeted that Israel was
quote-unquote hypnotizing the world and
then she spent years defending that
tweet suggesting there was nothing wrong
with the tweet and then in 2013 she gave
an interview to a person who called
Israel the Jewish Isis and compared
Hamas to Holocaust victims that was in
2013 in that same interview Omar
compared the United States military to
al-qaeda the accounts AG conservative
his good summary of all of this over at
Twitter at her inauguration Omar
celebrated with Linda Sarsour who
herself is a blatant and ridiculous
anti-semite she has come out as a
supporter of the anti-semitic BDS
movement which is boycott divest and
sanction Israel leaders of that movement
have been tied to terrorist groups as in
this week in late January omar argued
that Israel cannot be considered a
democracy because it is Jewish which is
insane since Muslims have more rights in
Israel than anywhere else in the Middle
East and by the way there are plenty of
democratic countries that have
established state religions and now she
comes out and suggests that the reason
that Republicans support Israel is
because they're being paid off so she
tweeted a couple of things over the
weekend here is what she tweeted first
she tweeted let me find the the first
tweet the first tweet was in response to
Glenn Greenwald who himself is a rabid
anti-israel anti-semite he's a
self-hating Jew he wrote GOP leader
Kevin McCarthy threatens punishment for
Ilhan Ilhan Omar and Rashida tribe over
their criticisms of Israel it's stunning
how much time US political leaders spend
defending a foreign nation even if it
means attacking free speech rights of
Americans nobody is attacking the free
speech rights of Ilhan Omar and Rashida
it's live
they're sitting in Congress they're
sitting in Congress they have not had
their free speech rights violated and
yet there's Glenn Greenwald suggesting
that all of these Republicans are doing
something deeply wrong by mentioning
Ilhan Omar and Rasheeda to lie both of
whom happened to be radical anti-semites
so Ilhan Omar tweeted out quote it's all
about the Benjamins baby with little
music symbol now as a Jew one of the oft
used anti-semitic tropes and this has
been true for thousands of years is that
the Jews control the monetary systems
with their shekels that the Jews are an
evil nefarious force behind world events
spreading around money and that the
reason that people support the Jews is
because they've been corrupted by the
Jew gold it's been the Jew gold behind
Republican support for the State of
Israel which of course is a complete lie
the vast majority of Americans support
Israel and support Jews because they're
not anti-semitic and because they
recognize that Israel is fighting
against some of the worst people on
planet Earth
it isn't really a hard choice when you
have a choice between democratic country
that respects individual rights and evil
Islamist dictatorship that tries to
murder civilians in their bed right not
a hard choice for most Americans very
hard choice for a lot of Democrats
apparently Ilhan Omar though suggests
that the reason Republicans support
Israel is because they're being paid off
by the Jew gold so she tweets that out
it's all about the Benjamins baby and
then somebody asked for clarification
nobody bought younger sargon now I know
about you nice enough lady he and I've
had a couple of email exchanges I've
written a couple of columns for the
foreword where she is the editor the
foreword does is a very very left-wing
Jewish magazine they are more than happy
to cover for anti-semite so long as
those anti-semites can put a thin veneer
of social justice over there
anti-semitism she's bought you has spent
years trying to pretend that el Han Omar
and receded to live and ALC or these
months trying to pretend that these
three are not in fact anti-semites or in
league with anti-semites then she bends
over backwards to use moderate language
in response to si semitism from these
three so Bhatia tweeted out quote would
love to know who ella Han thinks is
paying American politicians to be
pro-israel though I think I can guess
bad form congresswoman that's the second
anti-semitic trope you've tweeted okay
which again is a pretty weak way of
putting this bad form bad form you think
that by yo was saying bad form about
Steve King he think by it was saying bad
form about Donald Trump after
Charlotte's
none of the folks on the left is funny
there their responses basically well I
wish you wouldn't use that language
wasn't I wish she would stop being a
rabid anti-semite who hates Jews it
wasn't maybe we shouldn't have elected
somebody like this it wasn't maybe we
should take her off the House Foreign
Affairs Committee where Ilhan Omar
currently sits it wasn't that it was you
know it's really bad for him that she
sort of let the cat out of the bag with
being a rabid anti-semite no I wish she
would sort of walk that back so Ilhan
omar doubled down in response to bhatia
anger Sargon who again is
extraordinarily left-wing so Bayete
tweeted would love to know who Ilhan
omar thinks is paying american
politicians to be pro-israel though I
think I can guess an Ohana March we
t-back AIPAC that would be the is the
American Israel Public Affairs Committee
number one AIPAC does not really make a
lot of contributions to politicians the
amount that they've spent on lobbying on
a yearly basis something like three
point five million dollars okay that is
nothing compared to the beer Lobby which
spends twenty million dollars a year
second of all it J Street spends a
nearly equivalent amount of money on
left-wing politicians the reason that
AIPAC gives money that they lobby the
reason that they lobby politicians is
for a particular purpose but if you
think that their lobbying number one is
restricted to people who are supremely
pro-israel that is not true
they had Barack Obama speak at the AIPAC
conference controversially they had Joe
Biden speak at the AIPAC conference
controversially the only person I'm
aware who has not been able to speak at
the AIPAC conference was Ron Paul so
they allow pretty much everybody to
speak at the AIPAC conference AIPAC does
not own does not own the United States
Congress by dint of paying people this
is sort of a similar trope to the idea
that people in America are pro-gun
because the NRA is signing them checks
except now it's the nefarious Drew's
suspending their sickles the shekel
masters spending their shekels trying to
convince Republican Congress people now
I have to mention one of the weird
things about this particular notion is
the idea that Congress people are able
to be bought and paid for if that were
the case wouldn't you think that AIPAC
would just ratchet up its spending and
buy a bunch of Democrats why is it that
everybody who's always worried about
campaign spending is themselves people
are themselves immune to such corruption
I remember asking this about John McCain
when John McCain was was talking about
campaign finance reform oh there's too
much money in politics people are buying
politicians weird John McCain you
haven't been bought so why is it that
you think everybody around you has been
bought but you have not
but there are certain rare instances in
which Congress people are actually
corrupt and take money from particular
lobbies to change their views that's
pretty rare most people who are who are
picking up support are picking up
support because they pre held those
views most people who are pro-israel
we're pro-israel long before they had
ever heard of AIPAC well all of this
drew some fire even from some members of
the Democratic caucus congressman max
Rose who's a Jew from New York he
tweeted out when someone uses hateful
and offensive tropes and words against
people of any faith I will not be silent
congresswoman Omar statements are deeply
hurtful to Jews including myself
implying that Americans support Israel
because money alone is offensive enough
but to go a step further and retweet
someone's clearing their pain at her
sentiment is simply unacceptable what
happened is in ohan Omar mistakenly
retweeted somebody who said she's
obviously targeting the Jews this is no
different from her calling Jews
hook-nosed and she retweeted it and then
she Unruh tweeted it after she realized
what she had retweeted so max Roe says
at a time when anti-semitic attacks are
on the rise our leaders should not be
invoking hurtful stereotypes and
caricatures of Jewish people to dismiss
those who support Israel and the
Democratic Party and in the United
States of America we celebrate the
diversity of our people and the gods we
pray to as a strength the
congresswoman's statements do not live
up to that cherished ideal here's the
reality if you were calling like I was
for a sit for a move toward Senate or a
censorship motion against Steve King for
example which a lot of people in the
Democratic Party we're calling for how
do you not have a censorship of a
resolution of censure against Ilhan Omar
for all of this and the reason is
because the Democratic Party deep down
actually agrees of Ilhan Omar the
Democratic Party unfortunately has
become a party that is replete with
anti-semitism and certainly with
anti-israel activity I was there in 2012
when the idea of Jerusalem as Israel's
capital was booed at their convention
AOC is having phone calls with open
anti-semite Jeremy Corbyn in Britain and
then pretending she doesn't know what's
going on it's a bunch of nonsense
because the willingness to consort with
open jew-hating in the Democratic Party
is pretty obvious at this point
Nancy Pelosi so far has been pretty
silent on this Chelsea Clinton tweeted
that she would reach out to Omar's
office and then Omar tweeted that she'd
be happy to chat with Clinton so here's
hilarious so Chelsea Clinton tweeted out
that she'd be happy to talk with with
Ella and Omar and then she was hit by
Bernie Sanders supporters with how dare
you attack
Ilhan Omar and Melissa Bern is a Bernie
Sanders sight
she said disappointed Chelsea Clinton is
piling on Ilhan instead of reaching out
to her she is a new member of Congress
and figuring out how to navigate calling
out a PAC which is a terrible
organization aligned with Bibi and
learning that a lot of folks will assume
the worst there's nothing to assume
Eloheinu Omar has repeatedly invoked
anti-semitic tropes because she's an
anti-semite at a certain point when
someone is in your face not dog
whistling but screaming in your face
they don't like Jews are we just
supposed to pretend that they that this
is all a figment of our imagination is
that where we're supposed to go with
this so Chelsea Clinton responded hi
Melissa I will reach out to her tomorrow
I also think we have to call out
anti-semitic language and tropes on all
sides particularly in our elected
officials and particularly now and then
Ilhan omar tweeted back at Chelsea
Clinton Chelsea I would be happy to talk
we must call out smears from the GOP and
their allies and I believe we can do
that without criticizing people for
their faith I look forward to building
an inclusive movement for justice with
you and Chelsea Clinton then backed off
and replied hello congresswoman
completely agree I will reach out to
your office tomorrow looking forward to
connecting about this thread and more
Chelsea weird I don't remember
Republican leaders saying about Steve
King I look forward to connecting with
Steve King to get clarification on his
comments I don't remember them doing the
same thing with with Roy Moore I don't
remember
Republicans really doing the same thing
with pretty much anybody and this is not
the same Republicans are superior to
Democrats in every way this is to
suggest that Democrats are perfectly
willing to overlook anti-semitism in
their own party I'll get some more of
this in just one second I mean this is
this is a sickness inside the Democratic
Party I will explain in a second why
this sickness is allowed to thrive
inside the Democratic Party it's really
disgusting first let's talk about your
plans for Valentine's Day so this
Valentine's Day I know you're gonna go
down to the local grocery store gonna
pick up a box of Hershey's and then
you're gonna give it to your loved one
it ain't gonna cut it
here's what you really should do you
should go get some cherries berries I'm
telling you this is the best stuff on
planet Earth
so Sherry's berry sent us a sampler and
they sent me over some kosher stuff oh
my god this is some of the best stuff I
have ever eaten my kids go crazy for it
my wife goes crazy for it never go wrong
with their signature dipped
strawberries dipped in milk dark or
white chocolaty goodness for any
discerning palate she will fall in love
with every bite they also have
chocolate-covered chocolaty goodness
covered cookies and and and chocolatey
goodness covered caramel to me it's just
it's amazing go check out all of their
products right now and it all arrives
fresh with 100% cherries berries
guarantee ships anywhere nationally give
sweet something's to your long-distance
love Valentine's Day is right around the
corner send her the Valentine's Day gift
of her dreams at a price of your dreams
starting at just $19.99 plus shipping
and handling so you look great and you
send something awesome go check it out
right now
order now make this Valentine's Day
really special by getting double the
berries for just ten bucks more go to
berries calm click on the microphone
enter my promo code Ben's show at
checkout that's BER RI es com click that
microphone enter code Ben's show order
today that is Barry's calm enter code
Ben's show right now okay so a few
Democrats have come out and condemned
ill Hanauma or suggested they're gonna
have conversations with Ilhan omar
represented Josh got high Murr who is a
congressperson from New Jersey's fifth
district he tweeted out for nearly two
weeks
representative Ilhan Omar has avoided
meeting with me to discuss why
anti-semitic tropes like these are
hurtful to so many Americans there's
absolutely no place for this rhetoric in
Congress or anywhere and immediately he
was hit with charges from his own side
that he was undermining the fresh faces
of the Democratic Party representative
jim Himes of connecticut actually came
forward and said you know what this
isn't a really big deal this isn't you
know we should stop we should stop
making such a fuss over this he told CNN
that people in public office should be
comfortable saying what they would want
to say it really is honestly it's
incredible he said it's perfectly
legitimate to criticize Israel or the
pro Israel Israeli Lobby just be please
just please be careful to do it in a way
that can't be interpreted as being
anti-semitic it's not that people are
interpreting her words as anti-semitic
she is invoking anti-semitic stereotypes
end of story the same party that spots a
dog whistle behind everybody whoever
dressed as Michael Jackson in 1982 is
saying that when a woman comes forward
and says the Jews are paying the
Congress to be pro-israel that is not in
fact anti-semitism if you believe those
two things simultaneously you can just
go screw off I mean honest to god it's
so dishonest it we'll get to that in
just a second so dan Kildee is another
member of the Democratic House and dan
Kildee was on this morning talking
he represents the fifth District of
Michigan and this morning he suggested
on CNN that in fact her tweet was not
anti-semitism she's just you know
unsophisticated she's a newbie doesn't
matter she has had a consistent pattern
of anti-semitism for years and years and
years she's a newbie let's let's give
her the benefit of the doubt I wouldn't
take it as anti-semitism I would say
that she probably objects to the fact
that when it comes to issues around
foreign policy or welcomes the issue
specifically to Israel there are a lot
of interests a lot of folks who who make
campaign contributions based on a
person's position on Israel I I know
congresswoman Omar I don't believe that
she would Harbor those sorts of views as
they've been characterized but obviously
it's a problem that she sees that she
wants to address okay that's a joke
that's a joke of course she knows
exactly what she is saying she's been in
anti-semite for years it's again when
there's a pattern and the pattern is not
just a pattern that is close to obvious
it is perfectly obvious at a certain
point you have to say oh maybe the
person is an anti-semite the Democratic
Party is trying to cover for Ella hanim
are because they have an intersectional
conflict here is the intersectional
conflict for Democrats Ilhan Omar is in
Somalia and she's Muslim therefore she
Trump's Jews on the scale of
hierarchical victimhood and therefore we
must pretend that she is not an
anti-semite this is the way that it
works if you are higher on the
intersectional pyramid in terms of the
level of victimhood then you get to
insult at will people who are below you
on the intersectional pyramid you get to
suggest anything you want about those
groups you can say anything Jews do not
count as part of the intersectional
coalition we have seen this over and
over and over from the Democrats in the
last several years we have seen it at
the Women's March we're being pro-israel
Linda Sarsour said you cannot be a
feminist and pro-zionist she is still
introducing people like Kirsten
Gillibrand at rallies the members of the
women's March were endorsing Louis
Farrakhan no problem for years on end
until it finally became a national issue
about two years after the women's March
started and even then even then Linda
Sarsour is still welcome in the house of
the halls of power
AOC can hang out with Jeremy Corbyn why
well because she's woman and she's
Hispanic and because she's a communist
so she can obviously work with the
members of the of the labor in Britain
like Jeremy Corbyn who are openly
anti-semitic doesn't matter we'll just
pretend that that's not
anti-semitic in any way the Chicago
there's something called the Chicago
Dyke marshals they called themselves the
Lusby in March in Chicago they forced
people who were gay who were carrying a
flag with the Star of David on it not to
be part of the March because they
believe that that insulted other members
of their intersectional coalition when
it comes to intersectionality the theory
goes something like this people who
people who have been victimized by the
system of the United States must band
together to tear down that system but
Jews haven't been sufficiently
victimized by that system in the United
States they've been disproportionately
well-educated disproportionately wealthy
disproportionately powerful
disproportionately achievement-oriented
that means that they cannot be good
faith members of this coalition and
therefore if somebody else in the
coalition who has been more victimized
wants them out then the Jews go
the Jews are too successful to be part
of the dispossessed coalition and
therefore they are part of the possessed
coalition they're part of the hierarchy
that needs to be itself torn down this
is why the Democratic Party is suddenly
so tolerant of open anti-semitism inside
its own ranks Ilhan Omar is sitting on
the House Foreign Affairs Committee
she's a conspiratorial anti-semite she's
sitting on the House Foreign Affairs
Committee she's not the only one by the
way we're she to tell Abe is exactly the
same thing as Ilhan Omar when it comes
to these viewpoints
and we're supposed to sit here and
pretend that the Democratic Party is
friendly toward Jews where's Nancy
Pelosi pick up the red courtesy phone
Nancy isn't it time that you think about
who's sitting on your Foreign Affairs
Committee or is she just gonna pretend
that everything is totally fine am i
hitting my assumption is in the end she
will think that everything is totally
fine because why the hell not nobody in
the intersectional coalition including
Jews in the intersectional coalition
will say anything they are too scared of
being cast out all the leftist Jews who
vote from the Democratic Party who look
at things like Ilhan Omar and then shrug
and point at Donald Trump despite the
fact that Trump is significantly more
philo somatic and pro-israel than
anybody in the Democratic Party right
now the same Jews who will thrilled to
Chuck Schumer who voted against the Iran
deal while simultaneously allowing
Kirsten Gillibrand vote in favor of the
Iran deal the same Jews who will
proclaim that Barack Obama was some sort
of Pro Jewish force in the United States
when who's precisely the opposite those
same Jews are likely to look the other
way when it comes to Ella Hahn Omar
because the truth is there are a lot of
Jews in the United
States who don't care very much about
Judaism but do care an awful lot about
being members of the liberal coalition
that's their prerogative but the fact is
that this Democratic Party is
trafficking openly in anti-semitism at
this point embracing openly figures who
are anti-semitic and they have for years
and they have for years and to pretend
otherwise is simply a lie to watch it
forwarded by members of the media is
particularly going as I say you know
there are folks Dave why go who
sometimes can be a good reporter for The
Washington Post he tweeted out a little
bit earlier today that the real problem
is that people are taking Ilhan Omar
literally instead of seriously he said
as an expert on bad tweets it's obvious
that Omar is trying to broach a tricky /
forbidden topic and it's going to be
impossible for her if she keeps being
paid in on Twitter what's that tricky
isn't that tricky / forbidden topic
presumably the the involvement of a pack
or boycott divestment and sanctions
which actually is an anti-semitic
proposition so you have an actual
reporter from the Washington Post who
happens to be a left-wing reporter from
the Washington Post Dave talking about
how it's just Omar trying to Britt to
broach a tricky / forbidden topic oh I
remember exactly that same kind of
tolerance for every Republican who said
something vile they were just trying to
broach a topic that's all it was just a
topic broaching absolutely unbelievable
but we're gonna be told by the end of
the week that this is just Republicans
pouncing and them overreacting taehun
Omar and she's just you know she's
getting her feet under her her she's
just learning how Congress works she's
learning where the where the landmines
are and she stumbled on some
uncomfortable truths but she's learning
better now about how to handle herself
so it doesn't sound like she's
anti-semitic but we can't accuse her of
anti-semitism I mean we can't do that
and we wouldn't want to take a black
muslim congresswoman from somalia and
take her and then remove her from the
House Foreign Affairs Committee that
might be racist it's not anti-semitic
for her to say Jew gold is behind the
Republican position on Israel but it
would be anti-muslim and anti black if
we were to remove her from the House
Foreign Affairs Committee for doing
exactly that okay in just a second we're
going to talk about the media's
willingness to overlook the insanity of
the Democratic Party I mean really the
insanity of the fresh faces so fresh so
face inside the Democratic Party cuz it
ain't just el hanim R it is also AOC
we'll get to that in just one second
first let's talk about a simple fact we
are all
going to plotz at some point and when we
plots we want to make sure that our
families are not left bereft without any
sort of financial support well this is
why you need policy genius whether
you're an insurance expert or a newbie
policy genius has created a website that
makes it easy for you to compare quotes
get advice and get covered policy genius
is the easy way to get life insurance in
minutes you can compare quotes from top
insurers and find the coverage you need
at a price you can afford
from there you just apply online and the
advisors at policy genius handle all the
red tape for you they'll even negotiate
your rate with the insurance company no
extra fees no Commission sales agents
just helpful advice and personalized
service and policy genius doesn't just
make life insurance easy whether you're
shopping for disability insurance to
protect your income or homeowners
insurance or auto insurance they can
help you get covered fast so no matter
how much or how little you know about
life insurance you can find the right
policy in minutes and policy genius.com
it's the responsible thing for you to do
as an adult you want to make sure that
your family is not left without if god
forbid something should happen to you
and once you take care of it it honestly
feels really good because you don't have
to worry about it ever again go check it
out over a policy genius the easy way to
compare and buy life insurance policy
genius.com all right so it's not just
illa hon Omar the media are gonna cover
for they're also covering for AOC so AOC
made a complete fool of herself last
week because her team released an insane
green New Deal plan they released it on
her website it was up for hours and
hours and hours and hours and then it
was pulled down because this document
the six page document showed that the
Democratic program on the green New Deal
is fully insane it suggested we should
abolish airplanes in favor of trains it
suggested we were going to build
charging stations quote-unquote
everywhere that we were going to
retrofit or rebuild every building in
the United States it suggested that we
were going to make sure that we had
vacation time and full health care and
full parental leave and full payment for
people who were unable and unwilling to
work I mean the plan was full-scale
communism it was just a communist plan
it was openly red it was just full it
wasn't even green it was just red okay
and IOC put it up on her website and
then she removed it from her website and
then she lied about it so last Friday
night apparently on Tucker Carlson's
program one of a OCS top advisors was on
with Tucker Carlson talking about the
so-called green New Deal and he just
started lying about it he was asked
specifically about propositions in a OCS
document and he just said
that wasn't in the document I don't know
you're talking about that that was no we
never put anything like that up that's
not there and Tuckers like Oh what now
like I'm looking at the document and
this this advisor just is lying he's
just openly wise the guy's name is
Robert Hawkins a Cornell professor an
advisor to AOC and he says no no no no
no a OSI has never said anything like
that watch the why why would we ever pay
people who are quote unwilling to work i
we never would write an AOC has never
said anything like that right I think
you're referring to some sort of a
document that some I think some doctored
document that somebody other than us has
been circulating oh I thought that came
right from her that was in the
background her from her office is my
understand no no she's actually tweeted
it out to laugh at it if you look at her
latest tweets it seems that apparently
some Republicans have put it out there I
don't know well then thank you for
correcting me I mean because dick okay
um that's a lie that's a lie it wasn't a
background or put out by her office and
this idiot is mixing up a mock eye mock
version of the plan put out by a bunch
of Republicans making fun of her not
even Republican it's just generalized
right-wing people on Twitter mocking the
the plan that she put out I mean we went
we went over at word for word for
several hours last week it was not
something that was put out by
Republicans or something put out by aoc
because she's a dummy okay and because
her team is filled with dummies and this
guy is apparently another one of those
dummies so then a Oh see tweets this out
she tweeted out there are multiple
doctor gn0 agree New Deal resolutions
and and frequently asked questions
floating around there was also a draft
version that got uploaded and taken down
there's also draft versions floating out
there
point is the real one is our submitted
resolution House Resolution 109 so now
she's claiming that what there are some
versions that are doctored hey that's
just a why they're not doctored they're
satire again ALC has no capacity to
understand humor I know we pretend that
she actually has a sense of humor no not
true okay men she says well what this
actually was there's a draft version
that got uploaded a draft version of
your document that suggests that you
want to abolish trains and airplanes in
favor of trains and that you let's
assume that's all right how did that
even get into the drafting process first
of all it's a lie okay this was the most
coordinated release of a green new deal
in history
as it was it was legitimately
coordinated down to the nub within five
minutes of the HR resolution being
introduced it had been endorsed by four
separate 2020 presidential candidates
and that same hour this proposal went up
on Al C's website and ASU was the
co-sponsor in the house and she
specifically cited as the progenitor of
this green New Deal nonsense by all four
of the Democratic nominees in the summit
the Senate potential nominees in the
Senate who are running so the suggestion
is the most important day of a o'seas
life her political life in the green New
Deal and she puts out what an old draft
version that's the claim now and then it
got taken down weird because if it were
an old draft version you know what I
would have assumed like if somebody at
my office put up an old draft of an
article and then we realize it was an
old draft you know would go up the new
draft wouldn't that be the thing you'd
put up right you'd have it you'd have
like a background ER and a frequently
asked questions you say Oh God you know
that was the wrong version here's the
new version within five minutes we just
put up version 1.0 it's actually a
version 5.0 that should have gone up as
of today there is still no background or
FAQ on AOL C's website from what I can
see which means no you put up what you
wanted to put up and then you had to
take it down because you looked like a
dolt because you look like an idiot that
didn't stop the media the media actually
started running headlines about
Republicans pounced on AO C's accidental
release of the green new deal what they
really should be looking at is the House
Resolution now what's hilarious is to
watch the media change the narrative is
AOC changes the narrative so last week
you'll recall both the New York Times
and Politico defended the idiotic six
page documents itself they said well
it's breathtaking in its ambition and
scope it's incredible and what it seeks
to do maybe it's never gonna be
implemented but maybe that's the point
that's what Politico said now it's oh no
no no no no it wasn't it was an accident
guys he's silly of course it was never
realistic it was an accident
come on I mean she even said it was an
accident and then you started making fun
of her because it was an accident
it's unbelievable they they just they
shift on a dime and start mirroring a
o'seas narrative preferences the same
members of the media who she is
constantly ripping up and down as being
biased against her in full trumpian
fashion the only difference being the
media actually do hate Trump but they
adore AOC they're walking around with a
drool Cup
for aoc it's unbelievable they drool
more than my two and a half year old son
with a cold it's it's astonishing and
then they come to their final point in
the media and the final point when it
comes to the green new deal is you know
what it doesn't really matter what you
put up on our website it doesn't really
matter what she thinks it doesn't really
matter what policy proposals are put
forward all that matters is that if we
don't do something something millions
will dies you get Katy tur on MSNBC
doing this routine an objective news
host on MSNBC and she says look without
the green who do you millions will die
before we get to her clip let me just
explain the House Resolution provides 0
solutions none the house resolution just
says there should be a green new deal
that gets us off of carbon fuels that's
basically the entire text of the
resolution it doesn't say anything and
it's like saying we resolved this house
of Congress resolved that everyone in
the United States should be incredibly
wealthy and the media goes yeah well
without that resolution people would be
poor say you actually have to do
something as Congress to make your goal
happen but according to Katie Teeter the
real problem is not the Democrats are
proposing irresponsible silly ridiculous
counterproductive things that would not
in any way actually impact the economy
on a global impact the climate on a
global scale but will destroy the United
States economy the real key is that
without a resolution like this that is
absolutely nonsensical millions will die
which is a shock to me since I'm already
dead because of net neutrality
I already dead since Brett Kavanaugh is
on the Supreme Court I'm already dead
because of the tax cuts
I've died so many times at this point
since Trump was elected I mean I have
nine lives and I think so does everyone
else in the United States according to
Katie turn millions will die unless we
abide by a resolution that has no
specifics and does not explain how it
seeks to achieve what it wants to
achieve the UN said we have 12 years
before complete disaster you talked to
the representative of the Marshall
Islands and he's calling it what could
amount to genocide if we allow things to
go as they are the reports aren't just
hey it's gonna get bad the reports are
people will die millions and millions
and millions of people will die okay I
don't know which reports she's looking
at that millions and millions of people
will die again the implication for the
IPCC
see is that lots of people will have to
move that there will be significant
climate change over the next century
I'm always bewildered by the point made
by folks on the left that the water
levels will rise and thus millions will
die over the course of the next century
do Bjorn Lomborg makes this point does
he think that people are just gonna
start looking down at their feet and the
water is gonna be rising around their
feet you know what I'm gonna wait until
this thing rises a couple more meters
I'm just gonna like you look down at you
when it rains in your house do you
notice when it leaks into your house I
do would you notice if the water levels
rose enough that the water was now in
your house my guess is you would would
you stick around and wait for it to
reach nose level I highly doubt it
it's not gonna be day after tomorrow
it's not a giant tsunami that swamps all
of the coasts around the world that's
not how this works and yet without this
pointless resolution that actually does
not it doesn't even achieve what it
seeks to achieve as I mentioned last
week this resolution AO sees plan
suggested originally in the plan that
there would be no reliance and nuclear
power which is insane you can't go green
emissions if you don't use the nuclear
power but this this resolution doesn't
even touch what would happen with
climate change if the United States were
to get to zero emissions by 2030 it
would lower the global climate by
something like point point 1 to 4
degrees Celsius over the next century
that ain't gonna cut it you know who's
responsible for the growing level of
emissions in the world that would be
India China Brazil developing countries
not the first world anyway the Democrats
are embracing this stuff full-scale
because they've gone extraordinarily
radical we'll get to that in just a
second first lets us discuss your
sleeping arrangements so we're not going
to agree on everything but I think we
can all agree that we could use more
sleep
getting a good night's sleep is easier
if you're using Boleyn branches you
never think about your sheets you just
think that you can go down so like the
gas station pick up what that weird guy
is selling on the plastic table and it
says 1 million thread kind of like oh
that's probably great then you bring it
home and you realize it's an actual
plastic tarp well instead of that what
you should have is bull and branch eats
everything that they make is made from
pure 100% organic cotton which means
they start out super soft and they get
even softer over time you can buy
directly from them so you're essentially
paying wholesale prices luxury sheets
can cost up to 100 thousand bucks in the
store bull and branch sheets are only a
couple of hundred bucks everyone who
tries Boleyn branch sheets loves them we
have bull and branch eats in our house
we got rid of all our other sheets
because they're so comfortable even
three us
sleep on Boland Branch sheets shipping
is free you can try them for 30 nights
if you don't love them send them back
for refunds to get you started right now
my listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at bull and branch comm
promo code Ben that is bull and branch
comm today for 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets Bo LLM branch comm promo
code Ben once more Boleyn branch comm
promo code Ben used that promo code band
to get 50 bucks off your first set of
sheets alright so we're gonna get to the
2020 race and we are going to get to the
situation in Virginia in just a minute
first you're gonna have to go over to
daily wire and subscribe for $9.99 a
month you too can subscribe to daily
wire when you do you get the rest of
this show live and two additional hours
later because our podcast just isn't
long enough for you you want more
material and you can either listen to it
on live radio or if you want a
commercial free on demand you need to
subscribe also we do this fun thing
we're during some of the breaks I answer
your questions if you're if you're one
of our subscribers legitimately
thousands of subscribers watching live
every day and then thousands more
watching later our two hours so I mean
if you want that two hours who want to
interact with me more go check it out
for $9.99 a month nine dollars a year
also when you use $99 a year you get
this the very greatest and beverage
vessel is the leftist year is hot or
cold tumbler so many goodies behind the
paywall yet goodies during our daily
wire backstages you can ask questions
when we do our Q&A s you can ask
questions when we do tours they're their
new benefits that are gonna be coming
there we have all sorts of great things
that are happening once you get behind
that pay wall so go join the team it is
also the best way you can support the
show so we really do appreciate that
also subscribe over YouTube or iTunes we
have fantastic Sunday specials coming up
for you this last Sunday we had on Gary
Sinise world-famous actor and director
we talked about the military and we
talked about art it was really great and
next week we have someone else fantastic
so go check that out right now we're the
largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
as I say the Democrats have gone
incredibly radical and the media are
willing to bend over backwards to
pretend they are not so AOC puts out a
fully communist document pretends that
it was accidentally released and
pretends maybe that it was satire and
the media just go right along with it
Republicans pounced it on Omar openly
anti-semitic the media oh well maybe
she's just trying to broach a difficult
topic in an awkward way I mean honest to
god what the hell guys but the good news
is that the top-level Democrats are also
mirroring this stuff so Elizabeth Warren
who's desperately trying to remain
relevant after the implosion of her
campaign on the basis of her
native-american false ancestry claims
she came out over the weekend and she
said you know that green new deal we
must spend money on it it's time to
spend money she's trying to channel
Bernie Sanders except not as well so
here's here's Elizabeth Warren doing
that routine yesterday tired of hearing
what we can't afford because it's just
not true
well theists nation in the history of
the world of course we can afford these
investments stop stalling on spending
money real money on infrastructure and
clean energy and a green new deal life
is so charismatic by which I mean oh no
but I do love thee I'm tired of hearing
we can't spend money on things we have
unlimited money from my money machine
right here what's amazing about so many
of the Social Democrats in the
Democratic Party
yeah well distinguished socialists says
in Cuban Venezuela from Social Democrats
ie Denmark Norway what's so fascinating
about the quote unquote Social
Democratic Party is the Social
Democratic Party they don't actually
want any of the costs associated with
social democracy look at the tax rates
in Scandinavia the tax rates in Denmark
are 60% for people making above 60 grand
a year plus there is a value-added tax
that adds another 25% sales tax on top
of that so if you're a normal person
living in Denmark you're spending
upwards of 60% of the money that you
make every year going to the government
Democrats are never gonna tell you about
that ever Democrats don't want to
restrict immigration and yet all of the
Scandinavian countries have been
increasingly restricting immigration
because it turns out that when you open
a store
and put free stuff in the window and
then you don't restrict who comes in you
go bankrupt so Democrats a new theory is
something called modern monetary theory
which is basically just we can spend as
much money as we could possibly want and
no one will ever stop buying our bonds
which is only true so long as the United
States continues to be the world's top
producer of goods and services so long
as our economy is strong that is the
case but if we are spending endless
amounts of money and also regulating
endless amounts of businesses and taxing
them to death that's not going to be the
case it's all fun and games being the
leading economy on the planet until
you're not anymore
and then people stop funding all of
yours you're spending at which point you
have to inflate your way out or tax your
way out there's not enough money to tax
your way out so you have to inflate your
way out but I guess the new democratic
theory is that irresponsibility is an
actual economic strategy now listen
Republicans have had the same strategy
but at least they're not openly
proclaiming it at least Republicans
still pretend that they would like to
hemin spending at some point Democrats
like screw it man I mean let's just
going on a bender right here we're just
gonna spend as much money as we can
possibly print in the end pretty amazing
stuff but that was not the extent of
Elizabeth Warren's campaign over the
weekend the best moment of Elizabeth
Warren's campaign over the weekend was
her grabbing a small child and dragging
that small child it's a full view of the
camera this is pretty spectacular so
there's Elizabeth Warren on the stage I
don't know this kid is I mean maybe the
kids are relative I have no idea who
this kid is but she reaches over and
grabs this little kid who's wearing like
a blue jacket and just like Yanks the
kid in front of her get it over again
we're running for president get her over
here we need you in the frame it's great
like the kids just standing over there
all happy and then Elizabeth Warren just
like come here
no okay yanking that kid like a baby
from the womb good times over there at
the Elizabeth Warren campaign and then
she has to appeal to her her base and
her base not only wants endless spending
and apparently grabbing of children but
also they want her signaling that
President Trump might be in prison by
2020 so she was doing that routine over
the weekend as well you know here's what
bothers me the time we get to 2020
Donald Trump may not even be President
[Applause]
in fact he may not even be a free person
okay that that is just her obviously
like stroking the needs of the
Democratic base he might be gone well
yeah sure
provide the evidence and then well then
we'll talk about it meanwhile Amy
Klobuchar announced her campaign run was
hilarious is that she did it like in the
middle of the winter in the snow and
people were just getting hit by a
blizzard while she was out there which
for apparently senator Klobuchar that's
that's apparently what she does with her
bad staffers just throws them outdoors
naked and then she has them frozen there
bunch of stories last week about how she
mistreats her staffers and so here was
Amy clapper announcing her her run which
will and I think very much along the
same lines is just that lady is just a
dose of political valium so Amy
Klobuchar I think we can find for Walter
before it begins and Elizabeth Warren I
think he's in trouble also meanwhile
Willie Brown was slamming Kamala Harris
over the weekend which is pretty
hilarious so you'll recall the romantic
story of a six year old man stopping a
30 year old lady and then getting her
jobs on the state governmental level
which is what Willie Brown claims he was
doing back when he was mayor of San
Francisco and a top political kingmaker
in California Kamala Harris was at that
time an up-and-coming political junkie
and she started dating Willie Brown what
the time was married by the way in his
weekly column in the San Francisco
Chronicle Brown wrote make no mistake
president Trump State of the Union
address was the kickoff for his 2020
reelection campaign and so far I have
yet to see a Democrat who can beat him
the overnight polling after the speech
showed once again he connected with
voters at least enough voters to make
him a 2020 favorite you can't say the
same for the Democratic contenders they
all have impressive credentials winning
personalities and positive messages but
none displays the people personality
that our media savvy president has has
mastered Brown
knowledge last month according to
Breitbart he had dated Harris and given
her jobs that helped her early political
career so kind of a backhand and slap a
comely Harris nobody says Willie Brown
can actually beat President Trump at
current meanwhile Cory Booker is
campaigning in Iowa another inspiring
Spartacus moment because that's what
Spartacus did he went to Iowa Cory
Booker went to Iowa and pretended to be
the newfangled Obama he also had a very
very odd exchange with a reporter in
which a reporter came up to him and
started speaking with an accent and
Booker immediately assumed the guy was
speaking Spanish and so he said to habla
espanol and the guy was like no I'm from
Switzerland and Cory Booker was like oh
I don't speak Swiss because no one
speaks Swiss coz it's not a language
that's not a thing he says make it right
by the way if any Republican had said
that endless mockery Cory Booker says it
it's just another day being Cory Booker
man and then beta o Rourke is on the
campaign trail as well so beta or orc is
going to headline a rally today in El
Paso president Trump is set to hold a
rally in El Paso today to talk about the
government shutdown and the border it's
his first twenty20 campaign event
basically O'Rourke will join rally goers
in El Paso to show the country the
reality of the border there is in fact
large segments of border wall in El Paso
it is where border patrol is located
that's one of the reasons I'll Paso has
become a much safer city they've put out
a statement that says Boehner O'Rourke
will join with his city on Monday
evening to show the country the reality
of the border a vibrant safe by national
community that proudly celebrates its
culture history diversity and status as
a city of immigrants so Alaric
presumably will take out his bass guitar
and then he'll start singing smells like
teen spirit that's how he leads I mean I
just imagine that's how he leads off
every single rally with it with
rendition of smells like teen spirit
where he just dons his old sheep costume
from his earlier days and then he just
sings to himself I think that's that's
that's where it goes so you know good
good for bata Oh Rock it's a rather
uninspiring group of Democrats honestly
all president Trump has to do is shut
his face just be quiet let them talk let
them be stupid all will be well
I mean and proof of that is over in
Virginia where things have gone
poorly for the current governor of
Virginia he's trying to survive
politically he will survive politically
there is a poll out that shows that 60%
some 60% of blacks in Virginia want him
to remain as governor which shows that
even they are not supremely offended at
the whole in 1985 I dressed up in
blackface or as Michael Jackson
alternatively routine that doesn't mean
Ralph Northam is good at his job he's
very very bad at his job yesterday he
did his long-awaited interview in which
he was trying to rehabilitate himself
and he was asked why you should why
should you stay governor his answer
pretty fantastic why you think you still
deserve this job and so many people are
calling for you to step down well again
we we have worked very hard we've had a
good first year and and I'm a leader
I've been in some very difficult
situations life-and-death situations
taking care of sick children and right
now you're a doctor right now Virginia
needs someone that can heal there's no
better person to do that then a doctor
so I'm gonna stick around cuz I'm a
doctor and I'm gonna help people heal
that's a pretty great answer and by
great I mean that's an awful answer that
is one of the worst political answers in
fact that I have ever heard so I'm like
my wife's a doctor she's not governor of
Virginia nor is that a qualifier to be
governor of Virginia as it turns out and
the idea that you are a doctor and that
therefore you're a good person is also
weird there have been some pretty bad
doctors I can't wait for Gayle Kings
interview with dr. Murrow it's like why
should you be running this island it's
like wow as a doctor sure you know I
make human-animal hybrids but as a
doctor who best to bring people in
animals together than me dr. Moreau
oh well well done Ralph Northam I hope
he continues to be governor of Virginia
until he no longer is alright time for
some things I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like today
there's a great book that I've been
reading by Stephen C Meyer Stephen Meyer
is a professor of biology he is I'm
trying to member his exact financial PhD
from the University of Cambridge in the
philosophy of science
former geophysicist college professor he
directs the Center for science and
culture at the Discovery Institute in
Seattle this book is basically about the
theory of intelligence
now people mix up creationism and
intelligent design creationism is the
idea that the Bible is completely
literal and that the earth was completed
in six literal days that the dinosaurs
were basically non-existent that the
geological record of the world is
falsified by God or that is not what he
is talking about here in that sense I am
NOT a fundamentalist creationist right I
believe in the theory of evolution I
believe that the earth is billions of
years old I believe that humanity is
hundreds of thousands of years old I
agree with all of that stuff this is a
deeply scientifically knowledgeable book
basically asking some serious questions
about why it is that DNA seems to have
been designed and there are a bunch of
puzzles that people like Richard Dawkins
really have not provided sufficient
answers to is a 500 page book of heavy
science signature in the cell DNA
evidence for intelligent design well
worth the read who sent to me by a
listener from British Columbia actually
and it's taken me about a year to get
around to it I'd read another one of
Stephen Meyers books there they're all
very good and very well thought out
because there are significant scientific
realities that require some explanation
as to how evolution could have an
undirected fashion resulted in them so
for example DNA has to be created by
proteins but you need DNA in order to
create proteins so which came first DNA
or proteins there are certain basic
questions that why is it the DNA which
is an information coding system has to
it has to have a decoder how could the
decoder have evolved separately from the
DNA and there are all sorts of questions
scientifically speaking about whether
intelligent design is present in the
process and Stephen Meyer tries to make
the scientific case that the best
possible theory here is that there is in
fact an intelligent design to the
process of biology and evolution and
that that is a scientific theory a
science a scientific hypothesis the very
least that should be kept on the same
par as pure random chance which is what
folks like Dawkins or Sam Harris posit
for for the realities of evolution than
DNA biology so there's well worth the
read it's really interesting stuff okay
other things that I like today so I
should update you on the Jeff bisso
story very quickly so as you'll recall
last week there was a lot of speculation
by folks in the media that the reason
that the the source for American media
being the National Enquirer the source
for their ownership
the source for the the fact that they
had control of text messages from Jeff
Bezos of his junk to his then lover and
they had text messages from her to him
there was suggestion that that had come
from the White House and that that had
come from the federal government well
now it turns out that the person who
actually leads that stuff to the
National Enquirer was the mistress's
brother so it was a family problem that
didn't stop the media from running with
the theory that Trump was behind all of
it because Trump is behind everything
Trump is nefarious and evil and
therefore behind everything turns out
that that's not so true so just worthy
of note ok time for a quick thing that I
hate the love affair with the Obamas
just continues apace so last night at
the Grammys Michelle Obama showed up
because obviously Michelle Obama has
something like she's a cigarette she's a
very famous singer measure but she's
great at dance well but she's a really
great artist who's made great music that
no she's just a famous lady he's just a
famous politician that is left-wing and
is married Barack Obama and therefore
she was there hugging all of the
artistic figures at the Grammys because
she's a Hollywood candidate and there
are a lot of people who are speculating
she showed up at the Grammys because
maybe she'll throw her hat in the ring
for 2020
I think that's deeply unlikely think
much more likely she throws her hat in
the ring in 2024 or something it would
just be too much for the American people
I think to have Obama Trump Obama again
but she showed up at the Grammys anyway
because don't worry it's only Trump
who's made our politics into culture it
wasn't the Obamas at all Obama who
showed his face on every TV show this
side a new girl it's it's really MIT but
here was Michelle Obama at the Grammys
last night
[Applause]
so much social justice happening all
people love Michelle Obama I remember
when they did it for Maura blush at that
tell me people freaking out Michelle
Obama's here oh my god Wow nothing
better to do I mean was she gonna go and
read him Sunday night come on what I
love the most about Michelle Obama being
alongside all these artists is obviously
she's an artistic figure a deep
important artistic figure again this is
the same thing as Barack Obama deciding
he needed to show up at the baseball
all-star game to throw out the first
pitch and then he needed to show up
giving his draft picks and then he mean
at least Obama I guess was like a sport
see president I why Michelle Obama was
at the Grammys I don't know except the
people at the Grammys loved her so I
guess that their political preferences
have to be on full display but again
don't worry this is all just normal
non-political cultural stuff Hollywood
is not biased in any way they're just
catering to the market that is what we
have been told all righty so we'll be
back here a little bit later today we
have two more hours of programming which
is why you should subscribe so you can
go listen to that otherwise we'll see
you here tomorrow i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Adam sy events
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Joshua alvera production
assistant Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wired production
copyright daily wire 20 19